[Applause]
what were you saying to khabib they got
him so upset
because he was coming back you're
passing my pay raise but you'd be paying
me for this
bro i never i never talked about this
[ __ ] you know i
yeah you know it's crazy it looked like
you riled them up i'm not saying you did
but it looked like you might have riled
them up and you might be partially
responsible
for him jumping out the cage that's only
responsible bro
holy how he was out the camera he's
gonna jump off for anybody come on stop
it you see this right here and he's
gonna jump in of course
what were you saying some armenian [ __ ]
i didn't say anything
i was just making gestures what what i
was making hand gestures what type of
gestures were you doing like no
okay so i'll explain this to you yeah
okay so weeks before i posted a picture
yeah my instagram
can you go down so i posted a picture of
him with a pro patrol bottle
right okay oh because he doesn't drink
alcohol yeah so his
but his best friend manager posted like
y'all we're gonna [ __ ] you in the ass i
swear to god
you go look at the comments so i seen
that i was he was a boy he's like he's
my weirdo ali
abdelaziz or whatever don't bring that
[ __ ] stop it he's a peanut right
there
yeah he's a peanut head no no his other
boy he has a he has a russian manager he
has american manager
okay so he says something like that so
whatever the fight's going on
so my boy loses obviously i'm [ __ ]
hurt that's my one of my closest friends
i love conor so i'm like there so go
down i'll show you the picture it's
actually hilarious bro
we do you see his hairline you put me
down bro oh wait no you got here
now this is awkward by this way yo that
cake right there
looks like that's my excellent i'm not
talking about yeah that's that look like
might have
that's jay paul's girlfriend by the way
no it is
i'm gonna join yeah okay so anyway there
was a picture i posted
and i seen that guy so the fight ends
right his [ __ ] is
smacking me on the back so like in my
head which which picture you go
yeah you get his hairline there yeah he
looks like a little bit like planet of
the apes a little bit
right come on that's what it looks like
in person
[Laughter]
those guys are like yes smash
more than one word bro he's been in
america for like 20 years probably
making him speak one sentence
[ __ ] deandra thought
so go down here he can go down
so this picture right so the comment
sorry so the fight ends and they start
smack me on the back of me i thought it
was like the commission coming in to end
whatever yeah and i looked back and
there was the guy that said that so i
was like go back that's what is he is a
comment
yeah he was like yo we smash your ass
you know what you know how those guys
talk bro
he's like we smash ass talking like
don't you like yo guys we
on the back so i look back and it's him
so i'm like what the [ __ ] is i was
looking at him and all of a sudden he's
screaming on me
so i'm gonna go with the [ __ ] you're
like obviously bro i have my boys back
i don't know you're from new york bro
someone says [ __ ] by your boy we [ __ ]
fight yeah yeah i don't care bro yeah so
he's like
screaming and then like he throws a
mouthpiece i'm like oh come here [ __ ]
like that like i don't know what i said
like whatever
he jumps over then the fight comes and
never comes so like that was busy would
you get a shot off
bro watch it i want me to talk you
through the [ __ ] episode did you put
a little finger in his giggy hole yeah
he would have been the most action's
ever gone
i hit him with the overhand right clinch
in my head when he landed as you go
he might have nice hands i don't have
the best hands i'll say oh my clinch up
so i started glitching i was like
uppercut him all this oh really
he you landed on khabib then maybe
anybody bro i swear in my life
he was backing up the whole time i was
trying to engage in the fight if he
watched the video
he was backing up i was coming forward
as he always [ __ ] fight is awesome
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
and then the whole thing came over but
he was backing up like this he was
pulling away like
those guys those daggers standing guys
but they all pull back that's how it is
well watch out all the fights islam all
them they're all
like they pull back they don't wanna
they don't ever take the first step you
know they're always on their back foot
so when he jumped out i think he didn't
realize that yo this [ __ ] is
nice
so he jumped out and then i started
swinging on him and he just out there
bro do we have the video can we
what's the uh last picture i don't care
bro
i'm telling you it wasn't facts so you
would you
fight khabib if you had the opportunity
bro you know it is like in this game
what is he so good at it that's connor's
fight that's like that'd be like yo me
like yo can i yeah
that that's his fight bro and you think
conor takes him if they fight again bro
now i'm in that second but though with
the right camera you got them
he was your improper 12 you seen it he
wasn't as like but
he trained but i'm telling you he's one
of the best person i've ever trained
with in my life he's [ __ ] sick
so yeah he would see that okay let's
look at it so watch watch
watch i come forward i don't yeah who
takes it backwards up there
where is he at i can't see yeah you're
more policy on there yeah you got to
replay
oh i got here i got caught there look at
that oh yeah i'm getting if i can
restrain by [ __ ]
oh he comes down oh that's true you jump
oh the one who goes forward
yeah he thought the backwards stepped
the whole time is that just reflex
and then who came at you and swung yeah
i mean i'm from new york yeah
my boy andrew are you from new york too
nope okay so you don't look like you're
from new york
oh man yeah okay that's tough the
burrows it's a real tough thing
manhattan in real time come to chelsea
he's over there coming to chelsea
actually i think i've seen him before
those clubs interesting
[Laughter]
i was on my way to the straight club in
chelsea have you ever thought about
going to ufc
that's into the mic some people say that
into the mic sorry i get pissed off when
people say like
you know how much you got paid to fight
bellator no way
way more than anybody in the ufc the
only person that makes more money than
me is connor
really so where to go ask anybody i make
the most money they go bro
for one fight but there's no one that
came and compared to me
trust me that why you think i'm about
you come on stop it
so you have no interest going to ufc
just because they're more high profile
fighting oh
i get paid like do they pay me right b
of c like they don't pay you guys right
but exposure could be worth something
right it's probably got my own exposure
i don't know
i i'm a [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] machine
generally speaking i would
i would for a fighter who doesn't know
how to promote them put yourself in the
biggest thing
but if you know how to promote yourself
be honest take the most money i'm 2-0
you know a bunch of ufc fighters who's
more popular yeah yeah no no you have
your micro monster it's it is weird it's
genuinely weird
it's not i mean like these guys are
probably they're like [ __ ]
like talking to a wall i'm telling you i
know them i've been growing up in this
game bro
these guys are like they think it's just
like it's like these guys are like i
smell okay
no one cares about that [ __ ] give me the
future what is happening what's next
what do we have to look for i want to i
want the winner of jake and ben
100 now if it's ben 100
i'm not interested in that fight though